hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
right here in front of me
is the m1 macbook pro now previously i
made a gaming video using this machine
and i tested out games like ios and ipad
games
using side loading i played games under
rosetta i even
installed crossover and played some
windows games
like witcher 3 which ran incredibly well
i played team fortress 2 and other games
like diablo 3
however a lot of you guys were doubting
the performance you were saying that
those are old games
they don't count as aaa titles so in
this video i'm going to be doing
something a little bit different
i went to twitch.tv and i took a
screenshot of
the top 10 most popular most viewed
games right now the point of this video
is not to try and prove that the m1
macbook pro is a great
aaa gaming machine because it's not i
actually think that's coming next year
with the
m1x that chip is expected to have
anywhere from 40 to 45 000
metal graphics score compared to this
machine with the m1
which has around 22 000 but the point is
to try and see
that for people who want a macbook for
doing their work or
professional app usage if they can just
buy the macbook by itself
without having to buy another gaming pc
on top of that
the first game on that list was of
course minecraft so let's go ahead and
run it all right here we are in
minecraft
java the mac edition this is running
under rosetta emulation
as you can see you have the stats opened
up and i'm getting around
89 80 fps it does dip down sometimes
let's see 81
93 76 99 101
so i'll show you guys the graphics
settings right here we're set to the
full screen resolution current which is
basically
the native res that it has open looks
like it's actually 2048
by 1280 graphics set to fancy
that's maxed out smooth lighting maxed
out view bobbing on
clouds are set to fancy all of the
particles so this is basically maxed out
the render distance is set to 12 chunks
which is the default
so let's go back into here and you can
see we're getting 93 82 fps
so as you guys can see we are not
getting
any less than 60 fps this is running
perfectly smooth let's see what happens
if we turn it up let's do
render distance to 16
chunks fps going down 66 69 55
52 so looks like enabling higher render
distance
48 actually saw it does go down quite a
bit but as you can see
we're seeing incredibly far that's
actually the thing that has the biggest
impact
on the fps turn it down a little bit
let's go to 14
chunks and the fps went up a little bit
look at 63
68 80 right now so i've got to say that
the performance is really impressive
with everything maxed out even if you
want to turn up the render
distance as well now let's test out if i
basically turn everything
down let's go to fast turn off smooth
lighting
turn off the clouds particles basically
minimal render distance let's go to two
chunks
view bobbing off let's turn everything
down to the minimum and see what we get
152 fps 149.
so if you really want to turn the
settings down as you can see we're
getting great fps 146 i saw there as a
minimum
you could cook this up to a 144 hertz
display
if you really want to play it that high
of fps now let's test
out how hot the cpu is we're looking at
75 degrees celsius
the fans are idling gpu is at 97
so even with the gpu maxed out getting
really good performance
sitting at 75 degrees so there you go
minecraft runs
perfectly fine on these first m1
macbooks
next up on that list we have cs go so
let's go ahead and open the mac version
of steam as you can see i have it
installed right here so let's play
and here we are let's play some arms
race
by the way the speakers on these
macbooks are
just so much better than any other
laptop out there what's up bro
okay we are getting some weird i don't
know if it's like lag
or something but this is pretty stuttery
even though our fps
is decent for some reason this game has
been stuttering
as you can see it just went up above 100
fps
62 fps i think that's so far the lowest
i've seen 109
so it does fluctuate a little bit 64.
so i'll show you we are sitting at 1440
by 900 that is
pretty low the texture detail and the
effect detail is on medium so it's not
all the way down
but a lot of this other stuff i've
lowered trying to get better performance
i'm not sure why we're not getting that
good of performance in cs go
but let me just turn this up a little
bit show you 2048
by 1280. we are going lower 59
so we are getting less 51
definitely not the best 50 fps i think
if you want a perfect gaming experience
you're gonna have to go down to 1440 by
900
to get a minimum of 60 which is
really what you want so at this higher
resolution as you can see we went down
to like 46 fps
definitely not perfect so you are going
to want to turn it down
i found that 1440 by 900 was optimal
not the best graphics but it is playable
at a minimum
of 60 fps which is what you want so let
me show you we're sitting at
74 degrees celsius with the fans at idle
it's really not bad playing cs go on an
extremely
thin and light macbook pro now i'm back
playing at 1440x900 sitting at
6760fps right now
not too bad but what makes us the most
impressive is that we're running with an
integrated graphics chip that takes an
incredibly low amount of power
5.6 watts of power under full load which
is absolutely
unheard of because of that you get a
really special feature watch this
unplugging the power cable does not
change the performance as you can see
we're still running the same as before
that is exclusive to macbooks you cannot
get that with a windows laptop now with
that let's move on to the number three
most viewed game on twitch and that
is fortnite let's go ahead and play
alright here we are in the fortnite
settings as you can see we're set to
windowed full screen
with the resolution set to 1680 by 1050.
now that's because the aspect ratio is
16x10
it's not 16x9 so we can't do perfect
1080p
i've got the quality presets set to
medium except i've fully maxed out the
3d res to make sure
it's sitting at that resolution i've
turned off the motion blur the v-sync
and let's go ahead and get into the game
walking around it looks like we're at an
average about
80 fps looks like we're hitting 90
sometimes 84 85 this is actually really
good
and it's playing very smooth i'm not
noticing the weird stuttering
this is playing perfectly fine oh
someone's right here
get out of here bro what's up very good
sitting at around
i'd say 75 average fps
so far looks like we hit a minimum of 58
for a second right there
oh i see somebody watch this watch this
oh i missed what's he doing dude
got him now here's the kicker i don't
hear the fan
at all now here's something to put into
perspective earlier this year in may
we tested out the new 2020 1800
macbook pro as well as the base model we
hooked that up
to an egpu with a display and we were
getting an
average of 85 fps with the 1800
model and 65 fps with the
base 1300 model now that was at 1080p
set to high here we're set to a little
bit lower so 15
less than 1080p set to medium
but this is getting close to the
performance
of an egpu setup of last year's 1800
higher end macbook pro like that is
insane the point i'm trying to make here
is that this is still running under
rosetta
this is a mac x86 app it's not yet
optimized for apple silicon and we're
getting
performance like this a minimum of 58
fps and just to show you guys we're
sitting at 83 degrees celsius with the
fans
just above idle looks like 2600 rpm
that's about i don't know
20 25 85 degrees celsius with a gpu
maxed out cpu at 20
so not that bad it's definitely running
hot but keep in mind how
thin and light this macbook pro is now
with that let's move on to the number
four
game on that list which is of course
world of warcraft
and this is the only aaa title that has
been updated for apple silicon so it's
gonna be running natively
but unfortunately i do not have it
installed on this machine
and that is because we need the extra
storage for the brand new
cyberpunk 2077 which we are going to be
playing so we might actually have that
video out
so if we do definitely check it out
after this video but
i do have world of warcraft installed on
the base
1000 macbook air with the 7 core
gpu and it's fanless so let's switch
over to this machine
all right here we are and unfortunately
i don't play this game so i only have a
level 13 monk
but let's get right into it here we are
in the graphics settings as you can see
we're set to full screen windowed
2560 by 1600 that's native
resolution and 100 resolution scale and
we're set to 5 out of 10
for the graphics quality and here we are
just running around
like normal and we're getting about
let's see
52 53 fps right now
55 so not perfect but
pretty impressive for the graphics
settings that we're playing at
on a macbook air now let's see if we can
get into a dungeon
so here we are in a dungeon it looks
like we're getting about 44
fps right now so it went down 42 fps 41
so definitely not perfect
at these graphic settings keep in mind
we are using
the seven core macbook air right now
so you would be getting a little bit
better fps with the macbook pro with
eight
cores so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
go and i'm gonna turn down the graphics
quality to
three so now we are getting a little bit
better fps looks like look at that
60 fps looks like even in battle
set to graphics level three we're
sitting at a consistent
60 fps and obviously there's no fan
noise because there are no fans
and here we have a boss fight still
sitting at 60 guys
who would have thought you could play
wow on a fanless
macbook air alright so after playing for
about let's say 20 minutes let's check
on the temps
51 degrees celsius guys with no
fan at all the macbook pro would have at
least been at
idle so it would be helping the cooling
a bit but this has no fan
sitting at 51 so guys i'm blown away
by this performance we're back on the
macbook pro and next up on the list is
grand theft auto
5. now you might be wondering how is
that going to run
on apple silicon because that's a
windows game it's not available for the
mac
so i was using crossover to play a
couple of games i played witcher 3 i
played final fantasy 10 i played team
fortress 2.
so i was able to use that to play
windows games but unfortunately
grand theft auto 5 did not run because
during the installation
and while trying to run the game it
glitches out because
it can't load up the social club
launcher for some reason
so because of that i couldn't even get
it to turn on so that's unfortunate and
that's a
fail for this game but hopefully
crossover will be updated
soon and we might be able to get it to
run now let's move on to the number six
game on the twitch.tv list this is
league of legends
let's see how good a performance we get
alright here we are in league and i want
to show you guys the video settings
negative resolution 2560 by 1600 full
screen
everything maxed out on very high look
at this 78
80 fps right now no issues at all i have
not seen it go
below 60 at all so far now what makes
this even more interesting is that
i personally have a 2018
15 inch macbook pro with a dedicated
graphics card and that machine
cannot run league this well i actually
had to resort
to playing tft not league because it
just wouldn't run well at all it'd be
all stuttery and glitchy
i could not get this much fps which is
very very interesting that we're getting
this good performance
on the lower end 13 inch i just saw it
go down to 65
64 fps we are dipping down to 50 while
fighting the dragon
so as you guys can see getting pretty
decent fps now when we did fight the
dragon
it did go down to about 46 so if you
want to get
perfect or great fps you will want to
turn down the settings a little bit
maybe the resolution
or the actual quality and let's go ahead
and look at our temps
we're sitting at 59 degrees celsius
look at that 52 just a split second
later it just cooled down
the fan is off the fan's not even idling
playing league of legends that's how
easy it is for this game to run which is
crazy moving on to the number seven game
on that list
is among us obviously that's an
incredibly easy game but i have it here
in the steam
mac library so i'll just show you guys
and it looks like
for some reason it's not running in
steam
so let me switch over to crossover and
let me run the windows version of this
game as you can see we have crossover
open and within that we have the windows
version of steam
now this is the 14 day free trial so i'm
still using that
and this is what i used to play witcher
3 which is a windows game
i also played final fantasy 10 so if you
haven't seen
that gaming video definitely watch that
one after this
but here you go among us the windows
version here we are
running perfectly 60 fps solid as you'd
expect playing an easy
game like this but i mean there you go
mini games obviously worked perfectly
fine
all right we voted for kit oh
he's not the imposter uh yep
he was the imposter obviously that
worked fine the fan was off 68 degrees
celsius
no issues now moving on to the number
eight game on that list which is call of
duty war zone
unfortunately i tried to play it but it
did not even launch
there was an error using crossover so
that sucks it failed for a warzone at
least for now
number nine on that list is dota 2 and i
have it installed right here
on the mac version of steam so let's run
it here we are in dota 2
in the graphics settings now i messed
around with this already and i found
that the best graphics settings are
16 by 10 aspect ratio obviously 2048
by 1280 which is actually higher
than 1080p exclusive full screen now i
turned all the graphics down to the
lowest for some reason
the performance isn't as great in this
game everything is on low but i did
turn up the graphics render quality to
100
so it's running at that resolution and i
am just gonna do a solo practice with
bots game so
when i do leave this i don't upset
anybody here we are in game getting
let's see 88 fps
at these settings so the game obviously
does not look
very good but for some reason it doesn't
perform as well as the other games that
i've tested but
80 fps so now that i'm in battle looks
like 75
74 fps so still above 60.
in fact i haven't seen it go below 60
once
looks like even during this team fight
minimum of 68
fps not bad so even now in this
team fight no issues at all 60 fps
59 fps minimum all right here we have a
battle going on in mid
72 fps right now definitely not bad at
all
70 53 it just dipped to 53.52
so i'd say the performance is definitely
not that great
but you could turn down the resolution a
little bit lower if you wanted to
let's do that let's turn it down a
little bit more 1680
by 10.50 63 fps right now
69.70 with a bunch of stuff going on
all right team fight let's see 51 fps 47
right there wow it dipped
not the best experience for dota 2
unless you want to turn everything
really low like i don't know 1440x900
so after playing for about half an hour
let's go ahead and turn this off and
see our temps here there we go we're at
54 degrees
celsius the fans are still idling at
around
1200 rpm we just turned off dota 2 so
i'd say overall i'm extremely impressed
with the
the temps and the low fan noise while
playing these games
and finally the last game on that list
is
valorant and as you know that's a
windows game and unfortunately it's not
on steam
and any other launchers that have tried
using crossover
have not worked only steam so
unfortunately
i can't test out that game so now after
trying to test out and play
the top 10 most viewed games on twitch
here are my conclusions all in all we
were able to play and run
seven out of the top 10 games which is
actually very impressive for
a brand new apple silicon m1 mac after
less than a month
after its release and out of those seven
games i'd say that
at least five of them ran decently well
and
in general while playing those games the
highest temps that we saw were about
81 to 83 degrees celsius
and the fan speed only went up to around
25
of the maximum i could only hear it if i
got really close
to the macbook pro which does not happen
with any other windows laptop so here's
my final conclusion
if you want to buy the m1 macbook pro
for professional use
or just browsing the web getting
incredibly good battery life
you can do so and you can play some of
the most popular games
on the side and this makes me very
excited for next year because this is
the first apple silicon chip
with integrated graphics and next year
of course
we're expecting the m1x chip and i think
that is going to absolutely kill
for aaa gaming especially when a lot of
these bugs get ironed out
with crossover and more games get
updated
for apple silicon so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe
for our review of the m1 macbook pro
coming very soon
definitely check out the other gaming
videos that i did right over there
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you in the next video